most successful women got their money
why problems
relationship with the IQ um
I'm asking about outcomes so the women
with the most money did they get there
was it was it they're being so smart and
competent let's let's let's let's think
about I'm thinking about our female
billionaires one has a sex tape one
sells makeup and the others got their
money IMAX model and I work in
healthcare what Amex model you're you're
a model I'm a model okay and you work in
healthcare and I work in a healthcare
yes okay great and I have a black belt
in karate okay but I bet you he could
still say and if you say that Romans are
not clever no no she said she said the
men are more clever okay no um